[Music]
on this saturday night
impatience and anger during the pandemic
the protest over rights and restrictions
and the complicated fight to re-crush
the curve it's like treating the
population
like children out of control infernos
along america's west coast
it's a terrifying time right now how
long these fires could last
and the danger to canada's air quality
the fight to leave
lesbos desperation and frustration among
thousands of migrants
and the opponent that no playoffs can
eliminate you had to have pretty deep
pockets to get through this this covered
based leagues
what's the permanent game plan for
sports
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us like many canadians we are keeping an
eye on the upward trend of new coven 19
cases in this country
health officials are urging everyone to
continue efforts to stop the spread
as we navigate the reopening of schools
and businesses
despite the warnings and fears of a
second wave
there are people ignoring restrictions
intended to prevent new infections
but as mike cherle reports in one
province being defiant about wearing a
mask
could land you with a hefty fine
in montreal they marched for freedom
hundreds of people claim their rights
are being trampled on
by quebec's insistence they wear masks
to limit the spread of covet 19.
another large rally in ottawa was about
gun rights with roughly half of those
attending
ignoring mask and distancing rules
yesterday canada's top doctors said it
was events like these
that may determine future pandemic
decisions it's not a
simple level of which someone is going
to roll back a particular measure
but we we just have to watch it really
carefully so that things don't escalate
to the extent that we can't manage as of
now they're managing
but covet 19 is trending up after the
big wave in april and may
the number of covet 19 cases in canada
dipped in the summer
but recent weeks have seen some spikes
is it a second wave
that depends on how high the numbers go
we're in the slow boil phase
the first climb of the first post big
wave wave
it's not pleasant to watch people need
to understand this is how it's going to
be
for the next few months until something
miraculous happens like the arrival of a
highly efficacious
vaccine and the numbers will almost
certainly rise once new cases from the
start of the school year
are put into the system that could take
up to two weeks
and with cooler weather there's less
humidity which means covet 19 aerosol
droplets hang in the air longer
quebec for one isn't waiting as of this
weekend police will be able to find
people disobeying mask laws
up to six thousand dollars a
heavy-handed approach epidemiologists
aren't sure will work unfortunately it's
like treating the population
like children but this is kind of where
we are right now
with anti-mask rallies kids in school
and coveted complacency
what other options do the provinces have
mike dralek global news toronto
the concerns over a potential second
wave are raising questions about the
federal government's pandemic plan
going forward this week on the west
block mercedes stephenson raises those
worries with health minister patty haidu
and the conservative health critic
canada recorded
more than 600 daily cases of covet 19
almost every day this week numbers that
we haven't seen since early june
that has canadians asking whether their
government is doing enough to prepare
for a spike in cases this fall whether
that means
tightening restrictions at the border or
making sure that provinces territories
and municipalities
have what they need to respond covet 19
has
already claimed the lives of more than 9
000 canadians
with that in mind i asked health
minister patty haidu whether she stands
by her initial assessment
that covett19 posed a very low risk to
canadians
here's how she responded you know we've
always followed the advice of our public
health officials and in fact
at that time the risk to canadians was
indeed low there were very few cases in
canada
we were screening from the affected
countries and when it became apparent
that this virus was spreading
uncontrollably in countries that were
not reporting any cases we took even
stronger measures
of course you know there will be a full
review of how canada
dealt with the pandemic as i think all
countries will be looking at in terms of
strengthening
their processes for future outbreaks but
at that particular time of course
with very few cases and with a real
strong global effort to try and contain
the spread and and and not allow it to
spread across the globe
you know at that time the risk was
indeed load individual canadians
that response isn't good enough for
conservative health critic michelle
rempel garner
she says the federal government failed
to take all of the necessary precautions
they could have
and that she worries the government is
not prepared for what may come this fall
here's what she told me the only thing
that we have in their own words is that
blunt tool of an economic shutdown that
has cost so many canadians their jobs
it's just
it's unacceptable and i you know they're
talking about reviews
we don't need a review canadians died
and we're in one of the worst economic
crisis that our country has ever seen
there's your review
now they need a plan also on the show
i'll check in with globe and mail bureau
chief
bob fife talking about some of the
scandals the liberal government is
facing the shutdown of we this week
the charges laid against a former
liberal mp and bill mourinho former
finance minister
facing allegations he broke elections
law all that and more
coming up on the west block mercedes
stephenson in ottawa thanks mercedes
as if university or college isn't
stressful enough
add in the pandemic post-secondary
institutions across the country are
implementing a variety of approaches to
keep students safe
ross lord looks at the difficult task of
balancing normalcy
and keeping coven 19 in check their
school year hasn't even started
and these students at acadia university
are already being tested
on their discipline they're enduring 14
days of quarantine because they came to
nova scotia from outside atlantic canada
during their isolation period they're
also required to take three covet 19
tests until you get your first result
you can't actually come outside so
this is the first time i've been able to
come outside and they have earlier so
i've been just kind of watching them
from the window
schools like acadia have an advantage
there's been little to no
infection in the surrounding community
that could spread onto campus
but they also face a big challenge
welcoming students from other parts of
canada
and the world safely making sure that
they're self-isolating when they arrive
and also making sure that there's really
strong surveillance in place because we
have seen that it
it doesn't take a lot for cases to start
increasing
and so being able to find those quickly
and respond quickly is really important
rcmp have fined four nova scotia
students
one thousand dollars each for not
self-isolating
three year from saint francis xavier
university in anaganesh
one student is from acadia but when
classes begin later this month
students will have some flexibility
unlike many canadian universities that
are switching to online courses
acadia and a few others are offering
students a choice
they can study online or in class
i'm honestly fine with doing it in
person because so far everything else
has been really
set up super properly so i'm not too
concerned about that with like mandatory
masks and distancing
acadia declined to make anyone available
for comment but the student union
has reservations we've spoken seriously
to them
because frankly returning to
face-to-face
uh classes although it may be desired by
students is not the safest option
delicate positioning as post-secondary
students and administrators navigate the
pandemic
ross lord global news wolfville nova
scotia
oxford university and pharmaceutical
firm astrazeneca are set to resume
clinical trials on a potential covert 19
vaccine
in britain testing was paused for nearly
a week after a volunteer in the uk
developed unexplained symptoms of a rare
spinal cord inflammation
now that an independent safety review
has been completed the british trials
will move forward
astrazeneca says it's working with
international health authorities to
resume testing elsewhere
including in the u.s
smoke from wildfires along the u.s west
coast is hanging over parts of b.c
tonight
this is what it looks like in vancouver
it's hard to tell but behind the haze is
the city's iconic
lions gate bridge and this is what it
looked like just a few days ago
at one point today vancouver had the
worst air quality
in the world environment canada has
issued air quality advisories for almost
all of the province
the smoky skies are expected to stick
around for several days
the situation is far worse south of the
border
dozens of wildfires are burning from
washington state
all the way down to mexico at least 26
people have been killed
and more than a million hectares have
been scorched as jennifer johnson
explains
firefighters are struggling to get the
wildfires under control
the familiar glow of orange a daily
nightmare for millions of residents in
washington state
oregon and california hundreds of
out-of-control wildfires are scorching
the land
leaving death and destruction behind in
washington state jamie and jake highland
were camping with their one-year-old son
uriel
and couldn't escape in time the boy died
the parents
badly burned in my worst dreams i
couldn't imagine what my sister and
brother-in-law had to go through and to
do
everything they could to fight for their
lives and to protect their child
oregon officials are preparing for mass
fatalities dozens of people are missing
at least half a million residents have
been told to leave their homes
everything i've ever owned all my
memories stuff from my family is just
all gone
the heavy smoke is also threatening
lives right now our air quality ranks
the worst in the world
due to these fires residents are now
dealing with constant heavy ash
raining down in the midst of the covet
19 pandemic
it's been horrible actually i have
asthma so it's been hard for me to
haven't gone out
the infernos are wiping out entire
communities after the bear fire tore
through berry creek california there was
nothing left at the town's school fire
house
and its only market i cried i cried for
a long time
and the worst day in my life when i
heard that news
california's governor and many
scientists blame climate change for the
worst wildfires in the state's history
dry land and whipping winds have created
a deadly combination
preventing those on the front lines from
getting the upper hand
there is no down time because mother
nature doesn't give a shout
firefighters say they are facing the
most explosive blazes they have ever
seen
and warn the land is so dry these fires
could burn well
into the winter months jennifer johnson
global news
coming up the migrant crisis after a
fire at an overcrowded camp what will
the european union do
to help
at least 50 people are feared dead after
an unregulated gold mine collapsed in
the democratic republic of the congo
rescuers are digging through rubble
which has blocked the mine's entrance
days of torrential rain had flooded the
tunnels witnesses say people tried to
escape but the water's float was too
powerful
most of the victims are youth the
government is calling for two days of
mourning
thousands of asylum seekers have spent a
fourth night sleeping outside
after flames destroyed their camp a
series of deliberately set fires burned
down the notoriously overcrowded
moria refugee camp this week as redmond
shannon explains
the migrants are now demanding to leave
the greek island
of lesbos
desperation and hunger in the european
union
thousands of people stranded out in the
open air
with no shelter and little hope my
family needs a close maybe
some place to stay maybe
food and water
they are here because they used to live
here
the infamous maria refugee camp is no
more
it burned down over two nights this week
two fires gutted the overcrowded holding
facility
home to more than 12 000 people waiting
for their asylum applications to be
processed
authorities suggest the fires were set
by refugees protesting over covet 19
lockdown measures
france and germany are leading european
efforts to house about 400 people
mostly unaccompanied children and greece
is
sending ships to house about two
thousand others but many are not allowed
to move because of covet-19
new tents are being flown in because
locals have set up roadblocks
we're fed up says this community leader
we need facilities in which
these people can live humanely but also
for there to be security for the
surrounding villages
for five years both locals and migrants
have decried the camp as intolerable
for very different reasons you know what
started the fire it was
europe the european politicians started
the fire in moria camp
because they didn't there do their work
they let these people
to to go through all this for so many
years
and nothing changed the eu had tried to
resettle migrants among its 27 members
but countries couldn't agree to a deal
if each country take one thousand
refugees the problem is solved
in response to the fires german
chancellor angela merkel says
something must be done to establish a
common european migration policy
to share the burden but hammering out
any such deal will take time
something those sleeping in the ditches
of lesbos
do not have redmond shannon global news
london
after months of delays and decades of
ruthless war
the afghan government and the taliban
are finally meeting face to face
to talk peace the u.s helped broker a
deal between the two sides which
includes afghanistan agreeing to release
5 000 taliban prisoners
while the taliban says it would free a
thousand afghan troops
the u.s secretary of state says he knows
the negotiations will be tough but is
urging both sides to be patient
and respectful i think everyone
sitting here today knows that it took
hard work and sacrifice to reach this
moment
and it will require enormously hard work
and sacrifice to keep it alive
the deal also involves the u.s
withdrawing all of its troops from
afghanistan
by may still ahead an ontario couple
lost in the woods for days
and then found
you're watching global globalnational
[Music]
[Music]
toots hibbert one of reggae's founders
has died at the age of
77. hibbert gave the music its name and
helped make reggae an
international movement through songs
like pressure drop monkey man
and funking kingston hibbert passed away
in hospital in jamaica surrounded by
family they didn't say how he died
but the reggae giant was hospitalized
last month after showing symptoms
consistent
with the coronavirus after spending
nearly 50 years together an ontario
couple's decision to
split up may have saved their lives the
two were hiking in the woods and got
lost
it was four days before they decided the
only way to get out
was to separate each took a different
route karen lieberman shows us how they
managed to get back together
again cecilia and ted naismith an
ontario couple in their 70s are
recovering from what can only be
described as a harrowing ordeal
i was prepared to accept that i didn't
see any way out
their story has a happy ending but it's
how they went
from lost to found that makes it
interesting you don't lose hope you
should always try
to find your way out four days and three
nights alone
in the woods how one survives that says
this opp
officer is nothing short of a miracle
in my experience i would say it's very
rare that
basically everything was against him but
he had the will to push on it was ted's
disappearance that sparked the massive
search
and it was all thanks to cecilia in my
opinion she's the hero in this story
the two went missing in the township of
lake of bays located near huntsville in
the muskoka region
some two and a half hours north of
toronto the couple had been staying at a
cabin on oxbow
lake it's been in the family for a long
time so ted knows the area well
a picnic in the nearby woods seemed like
a good idea
but this is what they were facing very
thick
bush steep inclines
bodies of water whether it be lakes
rivers
everywhere very very wet wet rocks
lots of cliffs if you're wondering about
a cell phone neither ted
nor cecilia brought one they also hadn't
alerted friends and family
so when they got lost returning to the
cabin no one knew
as long as i keep walking i wanted to
keep walking you've got to try every
chance you have ted decided the couple
should separate
to search for help i took a lucky turn
on an atv trail
and that's how i got out cecilia
reported her husband missing
by then it was thursday they'd set out
on monday
time is definitely against us in that
case
we can't show you the search because a
camera crew couldn't make it through the
bush the way the opp
did by land air and water and i could
hear the helicopters overhead
but they couldn't see me and i couldn't
see them here is what ted
did see these three different types of
bears when
there was one cub the first one i ran
into was a mother in the cub
it was just nine degrees celsius and
stormy but the rescuers were tireless
they glanced over and he actually has a
bald head
and when their flashlights hit him they
he was right there
ted had been found hurting from his time
in the woods
and hypothermic you should know cecilia
that you know you
saved his life by doing what you did
getting out of the woods together
for nearly 50 years it was their brief
time apart
that led them back together karen
lieberman global news
up next can pro sports score a
sustainable
pandemic plan
the toronto raptors and their fans are
feeling heartbroken today
their dream of winning another nba
championship is now over
after the boston celtics won game seven
of the eastern conference
semifinal last night but no matter who
triumphs with the trophy and no matter
the league
the cloud of kova 19 will still hang
over them
morgan campbell tonight on the
sustainability of sports
during the pandemic
this is jurassic park the moment the
toronto raptors clinched the
2019 nba championship as
people flooded streets across canada
fast forward to
2020 like many other things this year
sports are looking much different and so
are viewing parties
not only did the raps lose their title
but they did it without fans in the
stands
it's disappointing we're glad we got it
to seven but
you know it was weird circumstances this
year you know celtics came strong and
their defense i do think was stronger
than the raptors defense
off the hard court the team and its
management are looking ahead to
next season pretty much the whole rest
of everything else we did
this year we played awesome you know
with overcoming a lot
and just never really wavered is this
bubble idea sustainable into the new
season i don't think it is
experts say while bumbling appears to
have worked so far with the nhl
and the nba the financial effect is
bound to take a toll
the marketing the hospitality you know
the bums and seats the tickets things
like that
are really going to hurt the smaller
teams remember what really drives all
these leagues is tv revenue
there is no doubts organizations are
looking to the national football league
to determine if fans can in fact return
to stadiums
the nfl is taking a huge risk right now
by doing this
the defending super bowl champion kansas
city chiefs kicked off the 2020
nfl season thursday night they did so
in front of about 17 thousand fans
that's 22 percent of arrowhead stadium's
capacity i think all the other sports
owners are sitting back and saying
we really hope this goes well for you
because then we can start to introduce
the same thing but whether that would be
something most fans would accept
we'll come back and take it next year
that's no problem or other major leagues
would adopt is
still up for debates morgan campbell
global news
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is this pair of
sculptured puffins
in st john's newfoundland and labrador
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so
email your photos thank you for watching
and i'll see you back here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you